l ormai bv friends and today we are con
il kymco dink co che sembra un po che
motivo king trova i cori fai cose però
non lo è più tardi dopo il funerale mia
madre più tardi e non ho fatto in tempo
a leggere
lei mi ha detto che non mi ha detto
niente grazie a casa è morta ha spento
ha speso più tempo con l'ago che con me
ok
porca [ __ ] che è successo e indicazioni
lo posso lanciare gli aghi che figata
mamma sei proprio tu questo l'ho detto
io non ha detto cosa faccio ma devo
tagliare le cose fighissimo è un gioco
impostato praticamente tu sei un tizio
che lancia gli aghi fighissimo senza un
senso se un drogato o dora e noli splace
conosco questo posto ma praticamente c'è
il protagonista che ha perso la mamma
che cuciva è molto carina come idea a
dal fuoco direttamente top la lanterna
al fuoco totalmente la casa la casa io
non in una casa del genere non cederei
mai il fuoco sarebbe già andata tutta
quanta in fiamme perché tutta di legno
che schifo ok
l'ho colpito ma che schifo che schifo
maledetti ragni schifosi che figata
avuto subito il ponte l'ho fatto solo
per il ragno non l'avevi sempre 1 e 2
ormai ho capito ma funziona e 1 e 2 3 4
meno male chi non sopporta ragazzi ho
provato una volta nella vita cucire e
stato un disastro non sono morto per
miracolo perché sono in grado di morire
anche o quello what bellissimo le schede
di signore o madonna consuma sempre più
sempre al mio calendario quando io mi
faccio il calendario degli impegni
ragazzi questo trova poi miei amici a
perché non trovi tempo guarda ad una
idea non ho fatto né può leggere gli
stage broken whatsapp non credo posso
cucire qualsiasi cosa quindi non sarà
broken manco per sbaglio
minchia il vento madonna ma chi le sa
pazzesca e cioè fatto sto gioco ragazzi
un genio che ha fatto sta roba
se ci pensate un'idea pazzesca questa
tutto starà nokia bassa abbastanza più
veloce vista che devo rompere il coso
quando quando si avvicina qua rompi a
sprint e no niente sprint ha fretta
ce l'ho fatta mam spray workshop del
giornale tra le boe domani si ok ma
andiamo a tutta la casa a fuoco
bellissimo comunque ma io penso
ero convinto di questo credo sia un
horror perché comunque penso che la
parte o la di vita poco perché io avevo
letto ecco mamma aspetta possiamo
parlare non lo vedi che è morta con
mamma non può essere lei o cristo
madonna cloro retorico arriverà c'è che
brutta roba ho visto c'è un ragno grosso
più grosso
c'era un run con credo fosse un ragno
c'è un omaggio di sì spero nopu dvd
audio di odio di video ma mi sono
schiantato fa niente come hai fatto ad
arrivare qui c'è una stanza chiusa aiuto
no non è vero
ora ti fermi da fermato non ci credo
sono fortissimi oddio cosa è sta roba
tutto sottosopra non capisco non è vero
sono vivo per milano non sono vivo mi ha
colpito mi ha fatto anche abbastanza
male ma fa niente mio diavolo dio mio
che è male ma che roba è sta a fare a
dio sono caduto giù a madonna maryville
e ragazzi c'è la cosa più brutta che
abbiamo visto top becca di questo dove
donna mi sa che era giusta la via dove
andare esattamente lì devo fare il giro
vieni qua fratello vesco non faccio il
giro ayane ha fatto male come ha fatto a
colpirmi
ok bene allora ho già unito un pezzo
teoricamente si unisco anche l'altro
siamo a posto che è 1 2 3 e 4 ai mici
unici che ce l'ho fatta ad avere lo
stesso corri aiuto cuore grato valuta di
giu mi chiami sono fatto mi farei
malissimo di solito ma niente cioè di
solito non è che io calda di solito li
dentro buchi così per l'amor di dio però
ai geni bello era il ps se funzionasse
veramente tirare gli aghi per unire le
cose sarebbe tutto un altro no cose che
lo schifo mamma poiché affitti di
studiare ha già sai che dosi già tempio
schmid kraus moon quiet lipu cristo
scusi e non funziona l'ho fatto non ha
funzionato neanche per sbaglio
che palle chiudi chiudi più di tutto
richiudi non ha chiuso
bravo sembra che faccio lo faccio io
faccio 500 che è successo
chicca rotto qualcosa chi si è sentito
male hanno lui ha rotto minchia
lui ha rotto da fare
se incastrato trovato dai corni luca
vicente una gates che katzav e di un
cancello posso tagliarlo taglia cancello
taglia che ci hanno tale cancello non lo
tagliano lo taglia mamma svetta dove sto
andando madonna ma che fico è fatto
sulla ragazzi bellissimo
dunque il mostro di ragno mi fanno
veramente vomitare potete fare un altro
maestra che le farfalle thank you for
the way ma prego no io ho detto alla mia
madre vive del workshop no war che
tradiscono e roero ero troppo fissato a
guardare la bellezza del tempio non ho
visto che c'è un fiume sorry
che carino velisti cespugli a forma di
palla di gelato mamma grazia che mai
segnato l'arte del cucire ma già finito
no era bellissimo ma come non ci credo
anthony sabatino la cosa va bene è stato
era bellissimo e non erano c'era un
horror un po cucito spero che vi sia
piaciuto per quanto corto perché
cortissimo ma proprio corto forte ai
early access expo bild ok perfetto che
mi faranno veramente bellissimo concept
bravi complimenti di tanto portiamo dei
giochi indie non che non fanno
particolarmente paura ma che sono fatti
bene a livello di concetto di arte spero
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi consensi che più
vi piace
iscrivetevi al canale e noi come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video e da
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma